y
[Música]
la segunda ola ya está en europa
siguiendo los pasos de francia el primer
ministro británico boris johnson anunció
un nuevo cierre de casi un mes en
inglaterra para frenar el avance del
coronavirus el confinamiento severo
llega después de que reinó unido-
superar el millón de casos
más de 90 millones de estadounidenses ya
han emitido su voto para las elecciones
presidenciales de este martes mientras
que donald trump joe biden y sus
principales aliados recorren este fin de
semana a estados cruciales en una
frenética carrera para movilizar a los
votantes enlazamos con un analista
electoral
sean connery reconocido por el papel de
james bond murió a los 90 años el
legendario actor escocés también ganó un
premio de la academia por la película
'los intocables' connery se retiró de la
actuación en 2005 tras una carrera de
cinco décadas
hola como estan saludamos con gusto a
todos ustedes que nos siguen por la
señal de france 24 mi nombre es alan
austria sean bienvenidos
empezamos en europa y es que el
continente vivió una jornada en la que
países como reino unido austria grecia o
portugal decidieron implementar
confinamientos totales o parciales para
frenar la segunda ola del coronavirus
este cierre supone otro duro golpe para
algunos sectores como restaurantes y
hoteles y ha provocado que cientos
salgan a protestar informe de álvaro
cordero
inglaterra se cocinará durante un mes
bares restaurantes y actividades no
esenciales cerrarán desde el próximo
jueves hasta el 2 de diciembre escocia
gales e irlanda del norte tendrán
autonomía sobre los cierres
ahora es momento de tomar medidas porque
no hay alternativa desde el jueves hasta
principios de diciembre debemos
quedarnos en casa
y sólo se podrá salir por cuestiones
específicas incluyendo educación trabajo
si es que no se puede hacer desde casa
para hacer ejercicio y recreación al
aire libre
al sol por razones médicas y para
escapar de lesiones o daños
intuit
para comprar alimentos y artículos
básicos y para brindar atención a
personas vulnerables como voluntarios
volunteer algo que se replica en casi
toda europa austria también impuso un
confinamiento de un mes y pierde
establecimientos no esenciales algo que
ya provocó protestas frente a la sede
gubernamental
grecia tendrá un cierre parcial donde
solo se verán afectados hoteles
restaurantes y la industria de la
cultura pero el comercio seguirá
operando en portugal por su parte se
anunció que el 70% de la población
estará confinada desde el 4 de noviembre
y en italia ante la posibilidad de
restricciones más duras cientos de
personas salieron a la calle a pedir
ayuda económica ver que evidente que
está claro que la crisis que seguirá y
que ha dañado la economía la pagará la
población y estamos aquí para hacer que
los patrones paguen la crisis me llamo
cooper falta caer a grecia de patrón es
el primer confinamiento ya golpeó con
dureza a la mayoría de países europeos
que vieron caídas históricas en su pib
ahora miles de personas temen que otro
encierro sea el golpe definitivo a sus
negocios y puestos de trabajo
eeuu registró en la última jornada más
de 100 mil casos positivos de kobe 19
las hospitalizaciones han ido en aumento
a medida que crece la curva de contagios
en la mayoría de los 50 estados algunos
de los más golpeados son precisamente
aquellos donde joe biden y donald trump
han intensificado sus actos de campaña
de cara a las elecciones del martes
andrés meza muñoz tiene los detalles
un récord a nivel mundial en sólo un día
a eeuu registró más de 100.000 casos
positivos de kobe 19 a finales de junio
el principal asesor médico de la casa
blanca había anticipado esta situación
instando a concentrar los esfuerzos
contra el virus en todo el país
ahora tenemos más de 40 mil casos nuevos
por día
no me sorprendería si tuviéramos a 100
mil diarios y esto no cambia y por eso
estoy muy preocupado en la mayoría de
los 50 estados del país han visto un
incremento en la curva de contagios
durante los últimos días y a medida que
los casos aumentan los hospitales se ven
cada vez más presionados de acuerdo con
el comité tracking proyecto una
iniciativa de voluntarios las
hospitalizaciones registraron un número
más alto desde mitades de agosto con
casi 47.000 entre los estados más
afectados hasta michigan carolina del
norte ohio pensilvania y wisconsin
coincidiendo con los lugares en los que
joe biden y donald trump han tenido
fuerte presencia en los últimos días en
medio de agitadas campañas electorales
con las que buscan cortejar a los
votantes indecisos y asegurar una
victoria en las elecciones
próximo martes ondeando la bandera
blanca y se ha rendido a este virus
el plan de joe biden es castigarnos con
cierres y nunca volveremos a cerrar
el país también alcanzó esta semana los
nueve millones de casos positivos lo que
representa cerca del 3 por ciento de la
población
eeuu ronda las 230 mil muertes
acumuladas los expertos advierten que la
llegada del invierno podría multiplicar
estas cifras y que lo peor está por
venir enlazamos con césar martínez
gomáriz él es analista electoral
veterano de las últimas cinco elecciones
presidenciales estadounidenses señor
martínez muchas gracias por esta
comunicación usted es especialista en el
voto latino qué pasa con esta que es la
principal minoría en eeuu cree que es
correcto identificarla como el gigante
dormido podría cambiar eso en estas
elecciones
alan siempre han sido la clave que
tenemos unos 32 millones de elegir de
votantes elegibles para votar lo que
hemos tenido siempre aparte de estar en
casi en 5 estados muy claves en una
población muy grande en estados para el
colegio electoral es estar en estados
que deciden la elección es el caso de la
florida donde también los latinos pueden
ser un factor decisivo
y también el estado de arizona e
inclusive en el estado de pensilvania
entonces definitivamente estudiante
dormido está despertando porque como
vemos casi 90 millones de personas han
votado ya anticipadamente y muchos de
ellos latinos lo vimos también en el
estado de texas donde el gobernador ado
trató de bloquear el voto mucho en las
ciudades donde hay muchos latinos y al
contrario eso motivó a que salieran más
latinos más latinos a participar desde
antes césar martínez te quiero preguntar
de esto que dijo hoy el presidente de
donald trump dijo que desea declarar el
primero de noviembre como el día
conmemorativo de los estadounidenses
asesinados por extranjeros ilegales es
que trump busca agitar la xenofobia como
estrategia electoral en esta recta final
no me extraña el comenzó llamando a los
inmigrantes mexicanos llamando unos
violadores criminales de toda clase de
insultos dijo muchas cosas ha dicho le
conozco hemos llamado siempre las
bofetadas de donald trump las trompadas
hacia nuestra comunidad y
definitivamente donald trump hace esto
para incitar estos son los estados
unidos de norteamérica y tristemente lo
quiere dividir en los estados rojos los
estados azules y los estados racistas
los estados normales ese es el grave
problema pero yo creo que él es lo que
está motivando va a pasar lo mismo que
pasó en el 2018 estas palabras dentro de
estas palabras duras hace que la gente
participe y voten tos yo creo que le
vamos a devolver las bofetadas con
monstruos
muy bien qué gusto hablar contigo césar
martínez gomáriz él es analista
electoral veterano de las últimas cinco
elecciones presidenciales
estadounidenses y como lo escucho
especialista en el voto latino y mire
finalizamos con el adiós acción con nery
el legendario actor escocés cuya carrera
cinematográfica de 5 décadas estuvo
dominada por el papel de james bond
falleció a los 90 años
mezclen
[Música]
conocido por su sigla mismo y por su
reputación de donjuán le dio vida al
agente james bond un rol que lo
catapultó al súper estrellato
pero los orígenes de john connor y se
alejan y por mucho del glamour
hollywoodense ha nacido en edimburgo en
1939 hijo de un padre camionero y una
madre que trabajaba en tareas de
limpieza connor y tuvo una larga serie
de empleos a lo largo de su juventud
incluyendo una temporada en la marina y
un tiempo como repartidor de leche su
hobby de levantamiento de pesas lo llevó
a obtener un lugar en la competencia de
mister universo en 1953
[Música]
jirones
con él y fue el primer actor en llevar a
la gente de ian fleming a la pantalla
grande protagonizando 6 películas de
james bond su imponente estatura de 187
en sus modales suaves lo hicieron
interpretar el rol con naturalidad era
tan creíble enfrentando a villanos como
seduciendo a mujeres pero con el tiempo
connery enfrentó acusaciones de
misoginia dentro y fuera del escenario
en una entrevista con playboy en 1973
dijo que no veía nada malo en pegarle a
las mujeres era una persona que no se
guardaba sus opiniones apoyaba
vehementemente la independencia escocesa
y apoyó el fallido referendo del 2014
continuó actuando hasta sus años dorados
ganando un oscar en 1988 por los
intocables cuando tenía casi 60 años con
un y fue nombrado como el hombre más
sexy del mundo por la revista people
ese mismo año protagonizó la película la
roca con catherine zeta-jones pero
siempre será recordado como el agente
secreto de su majestad
gracias siguen france24